ich hab gestern für die gruppe gemacht
und danach würde ich ganz oft gefragt ob
ich denn nicht auch mal im video zu
dieser vanillesoße machen kann dies
selber gemacht habe und deswegen habe
ich mich ganz dazu entschlossen einfach
dieses video zu drehen mit dem kurzen
basics über die vanillesoße und zwar
habe ich wenn meine buchte eine echte
sauce gemacht also eine die aus milch
und natürlich nach amilly schote besteht
aber ich hab mir gedacht da ja auch
viele vegetarisch oder sich auch vegan
ernähren oder einfach keinen daher
vanillesoße haben möchten habe ich mir
gedacht mach' ich heute einfach zwei
varianten
deswegen werde ich euch zuerst einmal
die erste variante dieser vanillesoße
vorstellen die ganz klassische und dann
später im video werde ich auch die
vegane variante machen und werde dazu
sogar eine sojamilch verwenden einfach
das ganze wirklich begangen zu machen
jetzt fand ich aber erstmal mit der
klassischen vanillesoße an und sei gut
für einmal den zutaten
wir brauchen drei 150 milliliter milch
fünf esslöffel zucker ich habe jetzt
hier vanillezucker genommen
ein teelöffel stärke eine vanilleschote
und streit eigelb zuerst gebe ich jetzt
die milch in einem kleinen topf in dem
ich auch die soße kochen werde gebe den
zucker und die speisestärke mit dazu und
stellt das ganze kurz zur seite
inzwischen halte ich dann schon mal die
vanilleschote und öffne sie und kratze
mit der rückseite meines messers das
vanillemark heraus
damit die soße noch vanilli geschmeckt
gebe ich das vanillemark und die
aufgekratzten vanilleschoten in den topf
und verrührt das ganze schön
natürlich kommen da auch noch die drei
eigelbe mit dazu und dann muss das ganze
richtig schön klümpchen verrührt waren
bei mittlerer bis mittel hoher hitze
frühere ich das ganze dann ständig bis
die sauce etwas eindeckt das dauert ein
paar minuten und sobald die soße kocht
und ihr die gewünschte konsistenz
erreicht habt könnt ihr sie vom
herunternehmen ich streiche meine soße
jetzt noch durch einen sieg damit
einfach keine klümpchen drinbleiben und
natürlich auch damit die vanilleschoten
entfernt werden
die konsistenz meiner soße ist jetzt
natürlich noch relativ flüssig weise
warm ist im kalten zustand wird sie dann
noch etwas dickflüssiger die soße werde
ich jetzt noch mit einer folie schön
abdecken
und wenn sie dann umfüllen ihr könnt
entweder so ein schraubglas nehmen oder
ein einmachglas ich nehme jetzt das
einmal glas weil es einfach dekorativer
aussieht und wer es einfach da rein
fühlen
falls ihr die soße verschenken wollt
müsst ihr natürlich auch die
gummidichtung von diesem glas einsetzen
aber da ich meine songs dasselbe
verhalten benutze ich die gummidichtung
jetzt nicht und verschließe den deckel
einfach ihr müsst euch einfach überlegen
ob ihr die soße kalt oder warm servieren
wollte sie kalt servieren wollte nicht
einfach etwas weniger stärke weil die
soße nach dem abkühlen etwas angedickt
ist und wenn es sie warm servieren wollt
könnt ihr etwas mehr stärke verwenden
damit die soße bereits im warmen zustand
gedeckt ist
die vanillesoße ist jetzt auch abgekühlt
ich zeige euch einfach wie die
konsistenz ist wenn sie kalt ist
und zwar ist die so also sieht ziemlich
dick und wenn er sie gerne etwas
flüssiger haben wollt gibt einfach noch
ein bisschen milch oder sahne dort als
mal probieren moment mit butt war
gotha
als platte raus
und ich finde sie gut
jetzt einfach verschließen mir gesagt
weil ich meine nicht verschenken
deswegen brauche ich da auch dieses
gummi jetzt nicht dazwischen war nichts
umgesetzt ein bisschen störend die
klassische vanillesoße hat natürlich
noch richtig schöne gelbe farbe sowie
man die vanillesoße eben auch kennt man
sie jetzt sowieso gleich mit vanillesoße
diese gelbe farbe
die hat sie natürlich von dem 1 wenn ihr
ab und zu auch mal vielleicht
vanillesoße aus der tüte gemacht habt
werdet ihr natürlich auch feststellen
dass diese auch gelblich sind das kommt
natürlich nicht durch ein eigelb sondern
durch den farbstoff und es macht einfach
der industrie so weil man einfach wenn
das so sei schon immer als geld kennt
man assoziiert immer die gelbe farbe mit
der vanille und eigentlich hat ist die
manuelle nicht farbig sondern hat diesen
schwarzen pünktchen also ist er schwarz
aber so macht man das eben in der
industrie und jetzt werde ich natürlich
meine vegane vanillesoße machen dann
kommt natürlich dann kein eigelb mit
rein und deswegen wird diese woche sonst
auch weiß bleiben manche machen dann so
dass sie zum beispiel safran oder kuba
nehmen
das ist auch ein gewürz mit dem fernen
sie dann die man in das große 1
ich finde es braucht man nicht unbedingt
weil entweder habe ich niemanden es in
der app enthalten ist dann bekommt sie
die farbe daher oder man hat eben eine
eisfreie vanillesoße und die bleibt
daneben weiß oder ebenso milchig weiß
und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal
meine vegane vanillesoße und sage euch
später was den geschmack für die vegane
variante nehme ich 500 milliliter
sojamilch und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
einfach die hier
globus gekauft haben wir ein ganz großes
regal mit glutenfrei und vegan und
schlaghose frei und die sojamilch habe
ich gewählt weil diese eben laktosefrei
und rein pflanzlich wollt ja das ganze
vegan machen
natürlich gibt es da auch andere
milchprodukte also zum beispiel er ist
die soja - aber es gibt auch reis mails
usw und die unterscheiden sich alle im
geschmack so habe ich jetzt zum beispiel
auch mal diesen phasen milch mitgenommen
und es ist einfach sinn einfach rasen
löste die dann mit wasser vermischt
werden und dann haselnüsse trinken habe
ich jetzt auch schon probiert es hat
wirklich in zwei lustigen geschmack
bisher aufsteht und damit kann man zum
beispiel bei smoothies machen und so
weiter und zum geschmackstage ist
einfach später noch mal was als 500
milliliter von diesem zu ja mit oder
reismilch mandl mit was auch immer
40 gramm zucker da habe ich jetzt wieder
vanillezucker genommen selbst gemacht
mit etwas zucker vermischt weil man ja
nicht ausgereicht hat 20 gramm
speisestärke da kommt ihr natürlich
falls ihr blut ihn frei diese
vanillesoße haben möchtet könnt ihr hier
maisstärke nehmen oder auch reis stärke
und eine vanilleschote natürlich wird
diese vanillesoße nicht so gelb wie die
normale vanillesoße ein bisschen farbe
bekommt sie durch die sohle
hier könnte sie aussehen die es leicht
cremefarben und hier gehen wir so
ähnlich vor wie bei der anderen war eine
soße ich werde zuerst das mark der
vanilleschote auskratzen und werde
dieses mal aber die vanilleschote wieder
zu meinem vanillezucker darzulegen ihnen
die dose weil ich einfach wieder eine
frische vanilleschote traute und weil
mir der vanille geschmack diesmal so
auch ausreicht werde dann alle zutaten
vermischen mit einem schneebesen werde
dann alle zutaten mit einem schneebesen
richtig schön glatt rühren und dann das
ganze auf dem herz mittlerer bis mittel
hoher hitze erhitzen so lange bis eben
die creme etwas dicker wird und ich eine
perfekte vandalismus habe anschließend
las ich die soße wird er mit einer folie
etwas abkühlen weil sie damit durch ein
sieb streichen und dann wieder abholen
und natürlich schmeckt diese vanille
sonst nicht mehr gut zu den buchten
sondern auch zb zu alles zu waffeln oder
zu anderen leckeren desserts die echte
vanille sauce schmeckt natürlich sehr
ärgerlich und sehr lecker viele rennen
vielleicht auch den echten geschmack der
nähe gar nicht kennen weil oft in der
industrie aus anilin benutzt wird dass
es diese künstliche vanille zwingen
verbindet ich zum beispiel auch
niemandem zucker weil ich einfach den
natürlichen vanille geschmack möchte und
auch meinen vanillezucker immer selber
machen wie ihr gesehen habt das ist auch
ganz einfach sparen einfach auch ein
bisschen geld weil man ihn sogar kostet
auch geld
und so habe ich einfach den natürlichen
vanillegeschmack die vanille sauce mit
sojamilch war natürlich jetzt vom
geschmack her etwas anders als sich
vegan ernähren
einfach auch mal die mit sojaprodukte
net weiß dass soja seinen eigenen
geschmack hat das ist jetzt nicht ganz
mein fall
also ich werde auch weiterhin in zukunft
gerne meine ängste vanillesoße machen
oder auch einfach nur eine soße ohne
aber mit normaler mensch aber wer den
geschmack
trotzdem mag oder ihn ersetzen möchte
nimmt eben dann reis milch oder eine
andere mehr nicht also ich finde den
geschmack da es gewöhnungsbedürftig aber
ich denke wenn man sich einfach vegan
ernähren möchte oder muss oder sich noch
kurse fallen muss finde ich kann man
sich an den geschmack gewöhnen
und ja man kann er einfach etwas mehr
vanille nehmen und so eben das ganze
verfeinern
ich hoffe dass ihr auf jeden fall mal
die selbstgemachte vanillesoße
ausprobieren werdet müsst ihr nicht
immer auch nur tüte zurückgreifen wobei
jetzt hier nicht alle typen produkte
verteufeln will
es gibt ja auch viele tüten produkte die
gut sind weil sie einfach zeit sparend
sind
aber man kann einfach alles selber
machen und ich denke dazu werde ich
vielleicht auch mal ein video machen ob
ich nicht auch mal was aus der tüte
gemacht habe oder eben nicht
wo war eigentlich ganz gut kennt aber es
gibt einfach ein paar fertige sachen die
ich auch fertig benutze weil es einfach
zeitsparend ist aber bei seiner nähe zu
finden ist kann man gerne auch mal
selber teelöffel in die hand nehmen und
es einfach selber machen
ich habe heute ganz genau 99 1000
youtube abonnenten und bin schon ganz
gespannt frau frontal mehr endlich sechs
sheffield wenn ich die 100000 knacken
und dann wird nämlich ein ganz tolles
video folgen damals ich euch einfach mal
was über mich erzählen und ja so ein
bisschen die geschichte und die zukunft
und ich werde dann auch ein schönes
gewinnspiel machen weil ich ja euch
angetroffen zu verdanken habe dass ich
überhaupt bei dieser zahlen gelandet bin
und ja da war ich schon die ganze zeit
drauf
und freue mich natürlich darauf wann es
endlich soweit ist auf jeden fall bis
die rezepte von den beiden vanillesoße
nach meinem blog geben auch www.welt.de
und ich freue mich einfach wieder aufs
nächste mal freue mich über eure
kommentare und biss